from Mean Girls to motherhood rachel
mcadams finally breaks her silence on
becoming a mom the actress who likes to
keep her life private she sat down for
an interview with The Sunday Times UK
and explained why she waited a long time
to reveal that she'd become a mom Rachel
said she simply quote didn't want to do
it before it was the right time which I
respect to keep that part private
absolutely she said I have 39 years of
me I was sick of me I was so happy to
put the focus on some other person I
waited a long time but she added that
she wanted to keep his life private
even if hers isn't but you have to
respect right a hundred percent and what
I love is that she also says that
motherhood has been the best thing to
happen to her you know she has had a
tremendous career and I love how I love
that comment that you just read of her
being you know she she's had 39 years of
herself time to be selfish and now it's
time to you know be a mom and and focus
on that and and protect that too you
know cause it's such a special time and
obviously like your child has no control
over the life that you brought that
right and to and so I totally get it
what's crazy - she also says she
actually distances her kids so much from
her public persona that she doesn't have
any TV screens on no tablets for her son
because TV time is bad for children you
know rot your brains isn't what they
used to tell us right yes right no but
all but that I love this she says pots
and pans have been such a good
babysitter yeah you know you'd have to
buy them anything no toys or anything
you just throw them into the kitchen it
sounds like but it looks like we're
gonna have to wait a little bit longer
for details we don't know a name yet she
you know she wants to keep that life
private and that's okay we'll just have
to keep there no we yeah all we can say
is congratulations your graduation
mystery life
[Music]
[Applause]